[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Nick Wright first things first
co-host on Fox Sports One good to have
you back on the program Seton would you
give Nick the poll question
we had who is in better shape uh from
the teams that just got knocked out the
Suns Knicks Warriors or Sixers going
forward next season who's in better oh
wow what a great question that must not
have been a Dan Patrick original happy
birthday by the way
um the Knicks
because
they have flexibility they have I think
a really solid two through eight they
just need the number one which I know is
really hard to get but they've kept
their powder dry they have the assets
they might be able to go get it you got
to move off Randall Jalen is better than
the biggest Brunson supporters could
vote for RJ finally showed some flashes
and all of a sudden by the way redraft
Dan Zion jaw RJ oh boy
at number one who'd have seen that
coming
um I've Loved Quinton Grimes since he
and my son played together in summer
Bowl in Houston he was a clear Pro when
he was 14 years old I like IQ they got a
resign heart now you gotta find the one
but ones could come available like I
don't know do you think Kevin Durant's
career is ending in Phoenix I don't
Joelle embiid could get ANSI in Philly
Giannis who knows like so I think it's
the Knicks I think the team in the worst
shape is
gosh that's hard I think they're all in
rough shape Dan I think the Warriors
have nowhere to go I ain't the Sixers
they're gonna lose Harden for nothing
probably that's not a dire loss but
listen you know how much I love embiid
guy's got to have one great playoff run
in him he hasn't had it yet and then the
Suns talk about new owner syndrome I
mean that guy is just out of his mind
and they have no you know Booker they're
probably in the second best spot because
they have Booker
um but Durant's 35 or he's not 35 but as
I apologize Steph's 35 Durant's I think
34.
um but in you know Durant's played 11
minutes post round two in the last five
years it's not great and so there's just
they I don't yeah I think it's the
Knicks believe it or not I actually
think it's the next yeah but to try to
get that one is going to cost you a lot
of the players you were telling me about
to try to get that one to go to the
Knicks and and today's player doesn't
really care about Madison Square Garden
the way you know we used to think about
Madison Square Garden you know Durant
and Kyrie didn't even think about going
there I don't know if it has that magic
there that they say that I mean what
would it cost for Giannis to go there or
Joel embiid to go there
no I think that listen I I the point you
make is right like what they would try
to do is
RJ Julius who at this point to me Julius
is a toxic asset like he's one of the LA
the worst playoff performers that's not
hyperbole of the last 30 years when you
look at what his field goal percentage
is and you know the drop-off it'd be
pardon me it'd be that and all the picks
in the world that they have and they do
have a lot of picks I think so you're
right you would have to kind of carve
away some of the team or you could try
to do it in free agency not this year
but next year this year's free agent
class is a bunch of you know B level
guys plus James Harden whatever you
think he is so that's a fair point but I
just think the Warriors are stuck they
have a great player who by the way are
we still kicking LeBron off Mount
Rushmore for Steph Curry I don't know
what's the update on that anybody
anybody uh I don't know I I just I I saw
LeBron in 65 000 minutes you know in 20
years and seemingly have the most gas
left in the tank in a game six but Steph
did score 50 in a game seven that record
lasted for 14 days but I neither here
nor there they've got no place to go the
Sixers are just kind of stuck do you do
Damon Tobias Harris plus a couple picks
I'm sorry Maxi and Tobias Harris plus a
couple picks for Dame maybe and then the
sun traded away all their depth to get
Durant they got a five four-man team and
one of the men DeAndre ayton just
objectively doesn't seem to like playing
basketball on the other man Chris Paul
is shorter than me and breaks down so I
think they're in really rough shape I
was wondering about this on return on
investment of of players in the NBA
and and Chris Paul would probably be at
the top that you've spent close to 400
million dollars and what do you get with
Chris Paul first ballot Hall of Famer
but there hasn't been postseason success
Kevin Durant gave you you know a title
in Boston he was over 300 million who's
uh who are some of the other players
that are on that that you know LeBron is
up there uh Durant's on that list uh who
else Seton uh Russell Westbrook Russell
Westbrook yeah so return on investment
where would Chris Paul be well in the
negative part of that I guess
turn it on its head what he instantly
does and has done at every stop of his
career is either give a franchise
credibility or take a franchise to the
next level just hasn't been able to take
him over the top the Hornets are nothing
in New Orleans he gets there there you
know what I mean in I think game seven
of round two in short order he goes the
Clippers they go from laughing stock to
Perennial playoff team he goes to the
Thunder everyone says they're tanking he
gets them to the playoffs the year of
the bubble he then goes to Phoenix
they're right there you know what I mean
they were they didn't they missed the
playoffs the bubble you're despite going
undefeated they get to the finals so I
do think he has impr I skipped the
Rockets who were you know a borderline
Contender his first year there they win
65 games they get to game seven of the
western Auburn's finals so I do think he
has improved every team he's gotten to
he just hasn't taken him over the top
but in his defense two little guys in
NBA history in the history of the league
two small players have been the best
player on Champions the eternally
underrated Isaiah Thomas and Steph Curry
who might at this point be a touch
overrated I'm not listen I'm not saying
he is I'm just saying well
he's overrate well I don't know I had to
listen that he might be better than
magic I had to listen that he's no doubt
no doubt top 10. who are you listening
to and maybe you need to get a better
group of friends
ever there's a lot of talk Dan it's a
lot of talk on television and the
interwebs the radio the way I heard
everybody's got a hot take that's all
they're trying to do I heard people say
if Steph wins this series if he wins
this series he might you know have
replaced LeBron on Mount Rushmore I
heard it that's crazy yeah I heard it
nice listen Steph by the way has now
played LeBron in the playoffs in Five
series six if we include the playing
game and he is over five on out playing
him over five not one Series has he out
played LeBron James in a series where
they've been on the court together uh
just up there I I have talked about this
last couple of weeks where everybody was
you know they they because it's LeBron
they diminish what he did in the bubble
it's like oh yeah but he did it in the
bubble and I'm like wait everybody had a
Level Playing Court there and they lost
they lost the home court advantage they
were the one seat yes the the book the
bump thing where we were like oh unfair
yes if an eight seed would have risen up
yes maybe they were they had a home
court advantage robbed from them and I
don't know if you've been watching
LeBron at Old Staples what we now call
the Crypt uh undefeated like Lavar ball
never lost in the postseason this year
that's 7-0 against a two seed and
against a defending champion and now
everyone's like oh it's the bubble it's
a fluke and now we have the exact same
final four and these frauds they're like
oh yeah but the teams are different no
they're not it's LeBron and A.D it's bam
and Jimmy it's Jalen and Tatum it's
jokic Murray and Michael Porter Jr yeah
the role players change of course
they've changed but it's the same top
top couple guys on every team and
LeBron's about do it again we've got to
have this by the way Lakers overheat
it's about to happen again
that's your pick for the finals yeah I
had Lakers over Sixers going into the
playoffs got the Lakers at 50-1 when
LeBron got hurt 50-1 Dan gave that out
on a very popular podcast that you never
promote on this show what's right with
Nick Wright that I do with my family and
friends
um
yes I do because he writes these things
down so I can get it correctly
but a year ago I told you I told you do
you tell Todd hey did you promote this
no because you and I have a personal
relationship that supersedes Todd with
respect to Todd you should know that
this is an important thing I'm trying to
build in the digital media space what's
right with Nick right with my son and my
daughter it's a family business not
everyone has an Empire they can pass
down Dan I'm trying to build it up as I
was saying I gave out that 50 to one on
what's right when they're great but
that's not the point point is what did
you get me for my birthday
oh I have it can you hold on hold on I
have it right here wait here Nick right
first things first and he's got some
kind of podcast here he some kind of
podcast that is so rude I'm so rude some
kind of Family podcast this is a it's
not a family podcast I got 110 000
YouTube subscribers Dan you could learn
something for me in the digital space my
friend it's not terrestrial radio but
it's something going uh it's upstairs
don't be jealous don't hate just just
Embrace don't hate him obviously jealous
that's fine all right I don't have it in
front of me so I can't show you but can
I tell you what it is yeah what I got
you nothing it's a beautiful bright
light
it's unbelievable is it fake is it your
fake one
no it's the real one you gave me it's
just it
oh you're re-gifting
well I'd hope decline I really like it I
wear it every day on television but if
you demand a gift you know I mean I you
know what I'll take it back no no yeah
no take it back you know what Dan I'm
that one has too much emotional value to
me I'm gonna send you a different one
I'm gonna send you a different one it
just seems like you're mad today you're
angry I'm not angry you always think I'm
angry I'm fired Up Guys how would you
describe you know Nick Wright's
personality demeanor today Paulie manic
it looks like he's in a bathrobe or
something like that I don't know we're
like a throw you look like The Big
Lebowski or something what are you
talking about I'm wearing a white
T-shirt two beautiful Diamond chains
more like a man Nicholas yeah it's a
Saint Nicholas Park New York State
Harlem jacket Seaton that's what how
would you describe Nick's demeanor I
think I think manic is exactly the word
it's perfect yeah
there's a little mad scientist or
something going on here today okay
you want to know you want to know what's
going on here yes I do okay I'll tell
you what's going on here we weren't on
TV Friday yeah because of NASCAR yeah
this is my first oh you're backed up it
takes to do media since LeBron ended the
Warriors run and then the left left step
disconsolate on the sideline and I and
I'm excited I have a lot to discuss here
and and you you know fritzy text me was
like hey can you come on tomorrow and I
flew overnight and I was like ah you
know it's probably in my best interest
to save this gold for the television
show 3 P.M on FS1 but because it's your
birthday and because I missed dinner
with you this weekend because I was out
of town I said you know what I'll give
this to Dan and then you start off with
a poll question about the Knicks instead
of just teeing me up with a Steph LeBron
thing I had 14 minutes ready for it
LeBron could have retired after the heat
could have retired after the Heat and
been one of the 10 greatest players ever
that's when Steph's whole run started so
Steph had a whole career that's top 10
worthy but after LeBron already had a
career that stopped 10 worthy and now
he's sitting here today and LeBron just
outplayed him LeBron's better but I'm
I'm on your team with LeBron
well then be a good teammate I I am I I
okay what would you do if you're the
commissioner with John Moran
well
all right
I'd call Danny Ainge and be like listen
I need a favor you have all these picks
you're going to send them to you yeah
yeah and then I tell you I'd be like
listen it's either a 20. it's either a
20-game suspension and you go play for
Salt Lake or you are you for a year or a
year okay like buddy how about a round
of applause for Nick here what
[Applause]
himself you got to go live in Salt Lake
City but the Grizzlies win more without
you than with you the the Jazz have all
these picks they're not going to get
wimpy let's make it happen assuming
that's what David Stern would do tell
you right now David Stern be like guess
what young man that's why we have a
franchise in Salt Lake City you've
always wondered why is there a franchise
for these exact reasons
um now in all seriousness here's the
thing
I in a yes there is part of me that
understands there is wild hypocrisy
about who we get upset seeing with guns
and who we don't like I'm pretty sure
you know there's about 28 states in the
country that what jaw did in that car
breaks zero laws
but that misses the point entirely in my
opinion if you focus on that it would
not be against the law if Jah repeatedly
and I apologize for the example but
posted personal sex tapes to Instagram
breaking no law I think the NBA would
say yeah don't love it can't have it and
here's the other reason that I think ja
could be should be in massive trouble
they gave him a total pass not on the
shotgun Willy's gun thing but on the
thing with the Pacers team bus remember
they were like we couldn't prove if the
laser pointer was attached to a gun like
it like somebody has a laser pointer
like it's 1998 and you're trying to
Blind a pilot in the air like idiot kids
used to nobody cares those around
anymore uh I now feel very confident
like well you've had five other
incidents involving firearms that means
either John himself or job was in a car
with someone who was pointing a pistol
at other NBA players
like I now feel confident that's what
happened so I think he's got to be in a
ton of trouble and it is shocking to me
that he could see
he missed out on 39 million dollars
because of the first things he would
have been all NBA that contract is baked
in 39 million
and then he does it again and his buddy
who he's with who is the buddy who has
been banned from the Grizzlies Arena so
that buddy has made some bad choices is
the one that has the common sense to as
soon as he sees the gun put the phone
down like oh crap what are we doing so I
don't know man
it's a it's a bad situation and I wonder
how different it would be for David
Stern as opposed to Adam Silver
completely different demeanor with those
two and I I want this makes Adam Silver
looks bad look bad because of what
happened the last time he got lied to
now what do you do
now in suspending for 20 games does that
matter I think it's I I think it'd be
harsher than that it also
it is a shame because NBA players have
gone from
jail Blazers malice at the palace some
of the unfair stuff that was thrown at
Iverson two I think the models for
American pro athletes they are so they
are you know really remember 25 years
ago this the horrible Sports Illustrated
cover where's Daddy and it was a little
black boy and was talking about the
absentee fathers in the NBA now it's
almost a problem that so many players
bring their kids to press conferences
like it's almost a workplace fight like
they're but super involved parents the
most some of the most charitable group
of Rich guys in the world are NBA guys
businessmen involved in the tech space
startups all of it and now I feel like
this is I I feel like this is much like
we've talked about how tiger or LeBron
have raised the economics for everyone
right this is not the same degree but
there's a degree of things like this
lower the economics for everybody nobody
wins from this and I don't get it now
I'm not a gun guy I I admittedly but I
just don't get it at all
it's great to talk to you
I you know what and I gotta tell you
that's my birthday present to you right
there I gave you I start you with a
great jazz Danny aing Salt Lake City
joke and I end with the most cogent four
minutes on the John Moran situation
you're gonna find anywhere in media
that's better than a Breitling that's
got that right there is probably worth
fifteen thousand dollars in radio so you
right there you flip it you send it to
them you had four good minutes out of
15.
yeah I was I was more like a LeBron 10
for 14. super efficient nine rebounds
nine assists while over out playing the
one everyone says gonna take you know
the other Mount Rushmore not everybody
said it we stopped enough people said it
some people were saying take a deep take
a deep breath just relax a little bit
save some juice for later on today on
that popular show first things first I
have a bunch of Fridays off during the
summer I hope to be invited in studio to
spend one with you oh
okay how about that all right okay oh
yeah if if you can do it but you know or
dinner you know like
yeah I know listen you we're way past
your break yes we are yes we do we'll do
both I'll talk to you later okay all
right okay that's new crying okay we're
back after this